le ministre vous êtes le dixième
successeur d'andré malraux à la lettre
de ce ministère qui a été créé pour lui
en 59 par le général de gaulle alors là
qui sont que j'ai envie de vous poser
pour commencer c'est à quoi sert un
ministre de la culture aussi à des pays
qui n'ont pas de ministre de la culture
il ya par exemple il s'agit ni à
l'allemagne en a pas au niveau fédéral
et puis ce mode de culture finalement ça
fait un peu rébarbatif zepa quelquefois
envie de changer de titre de vous
appeler je sais pas
le ministre de la création le ministre
de l' art de vivre ou bien le ministre
pour parler comme arthur contre le
ministre des forces de la joie par
exemple froid pour expliquer les choses
simplement
il faut dire d'abord que la culture
n'est pas la faire d'une poignée de
personnes
je dirais même que c'est la faire de
chacun sait la faire de chacun d'entre
nous de chacun d'entre vous au fond
c'est la part de rêve qui est en chacun
nous même le meilleur de nous mêmes la
culture c'est chez chacun le désir de
beauté le désir de participer pleinement
aux plaisirs de la vie et c'est un peu
la conception qui nous anime et dès le
départ une conception large une
conception généreuse qui ouvre les
portes ce ministère à tous ceux qui
souhaitent le reconnaître comme leur
maison
je veux dire en effet la maison de l'art
de vivre la maison de la beauté de
toutes les formes de beauté est parmi
les premiers changements qui ont été
apportés
il y a eu cette volonté que les portes
soient largement ouverte et ne montrent
notamment largement ouverte à tous ceux
qui avaient été trop longtemps écarté de
ce ministère je veux dire les jeunes
je veux dire les travailleurs je veux
dire aussi des formes d'art qui étaient
considérées comme marginales ou
accessoires qui n'étaient pas les
beaux-arts
je cite en vrac que le jazz la musique
populaire la bande dessinée la
photographie et nous avons voulu
reconnaître la chanson dont vous les
reconnaître à part entière comme des
formes d'art qui mérite elle-même
reconnaît
ce que la haute culture pour laquelle en
effet il faut faire un grand effort la
littérature le cinéma le théâtre et
toutes les formes d'art je crois que le
grand changement ou le premier des
changements que nous avons introduit
consiste à dire à chaque français la
culture c'est vous dans chacun de vos
actes de la vie quotidienne vous faites
acte de culture acte 2 transformations
acte de création de la beauté l'ouvrier
qui façonnent une pièce le paysan qui
arracha la terre un produit et qui nous
l'offre à nous habitants des villes pour
notre plaisir où notre satisfaction
matérielle
chacun participe à la beauté chacun est
un artisan de la culture et personne ne
doit en être exclus d'accord alors tout
ça on va le développer on va voir une
heure d'ailleurs pour le développer mais
et nous ne parlerons pas ce soir
seulement de politique culturelle parce
que je pense que les téléspectateurs
attendent de vous peut-être vous êtes
membre du gouvernement vous prononciez
sur des problèmes autre isotope
peut-être temps utile par exemple qu'on
leur parle des raisons de l'ocs leur
expliquer les raisons de la démission de
jean-pierre cot dont le professeur
mikowski qui est là dans ce studio qui
votre invité qui est derrière moi a
écrit ce matin dans libération que
c'était je cite l'événement le plus
graves intervenues dans la politique
gouvernementale depuis le 10 mai 1981
alors tout de suite pour lancer le débat
on va interroger svp où l'on commence à
recevoir des questions alors philippe
harrouard françois henry et bien
monsieur lang vous êtes ce soir la
télévision et la plupart des gens qui
nous ont appelés voudrais bien savoir ce
que vous pensez de la télévision
justement êtes-vous satisfait de notre
télévision et en particulier de la non
harmonisation des programmes
c'est un retraité d'avignon pensez vous
que la plupart des téléspectateurs
partage votre opinion sur l'orientation
culturelle des émissions que pensez-vous
de télévision votre jugement at il
changé depuis que vous exercez vos
fonctions il devrait y avoir des
créations très fréquentes à la
télévision mais il n'y en a pas depuis
longtemps
êtes vous satisfait des programmes
comment un ministre la culture peut-il
tolérer les grossièretés qui passent à
la télévision et la radio etc etc
j'en ai beaucoup voyez connelly vous
voyez qu'on élude aucune question même
le plus difficile pour nous alors
messieurs ministre la question la
télévision est une question qui est tant
mieux
qui oppose les avis les opinions et
parfois de façon
quand on l'entend à l'instant je dirais
que chacun d'entre nous vous moi quand
il réfléchit à la télévision idéale est
partagée au fond entre deux tentations
contradictoires l'une consiste à
concevoir des programmes qui viserait à
satisfaire un téléspectateur idéal un
téléspectateur moyen et on imagine
aussitôt les risques d'une telle
conception car à vouloir plaire à ses
téléspectateurs on risque de ne plaire à
personne et l'autre tentation c'est de
vouloir imposer ses propres goûts je
veux dire de choisir une télévision peut
être plus vivante mais qui n'est que
l'expression ses propres goûts et il
n'est pas facile de choisir entre une
télévision
je dirais standard et une télévision qui
serait l'expression ses propres goûts et
je crois que l'une des réponses
l'une des réponses et les dans l'avenir
je veux dire que lorsque d'ici quelques
temps très bientôt de nombreux réseaux
se feront au public
alors chacun aura le choix
chacun pourra choisir l'un une émission
d'europe l'autre un film un autre une
émission de gymnastique et on
substituera à une télévision menu fixe
une télévision à la carte
je crois beaucoup que l'avenir de la des
télécommunications c'est à dire la
diversification des réseaux permettront
à chaque téléspectateur de choisir un
programme selon ses goûts mais à la fin
du public moyen ce sera la fin du public
moyen jeu sera la fin aussi d'un système
dans lequel tel d'entre nous voudraient
imposer ses propres goûts d'accord alors
monsieur le ministre vous connaissez la
règle de l'émission vous aurez le choix
entre trois journalistes que j'ai
choisie vous avez choisi vous allez
tirer au sort l'ordre de leur passage
alors c'est monsieur monsieur ronald
coven du boston globe
oui alors ronald koeman être juriste
américain du boston globe qui est l'un
des quatre dans les cinq grands
quotidiens américains alors un américain
interlocuteur intéressante pour la
commune vous vous asseyez là pour un
ministre qui dit avoir reçu réassurer le
rayonnement international de la france
comme votre question je pense que le
ministre sera déçu si en tant
qu'américain je ne commençait pas
d'entrée de jeu de vous poser la
question que vous attendiez sans doute
sur votre discours avec syco cet été à
la réunion de l'unesco conférence
mondiale sur la culture
et vous où vous avez dit et je vous cite
nos pays sont ils des passoires et
doivent ils accepter sans réagir
ce bombardement d'image et sans aucune
réciprocité
notre destin est il de devenir les
vassaux de l'immense empire du profit
nous souhaitons que cette conférence
soit l'occasion pour les peuples à
travers leurs gouvernements des peuples
d'appeler à une véritable résistance
culturelle à une véritable croisade
contre 7,2 domination appelons les
choses par leur nom
cet impérialisme financiers et
intellectuels
alors ma question c'est voulez vous s'il
vous plaît définir cette croisade en
quoi elle consiste et où en est-on de
cette croisade
je dirais d'abord que les propositions
de la france qui ont été soumises à la
conférence de mexico on était à ponte
ont été approuvé par 90 % des délégués
présents et l'ensemble des propositions
reçues dans ce jeu dans son ensemble les
propositions de la france ont par
conséquent étaient approuvés
par l'ensemble des pays présents à
quelques exceptions près et je peux dire
que les thèses que notre pays a
développé à mexico ont obtenu un grand
succès mais je réponds à votre question
vous citer un extrait un extrait d'un
éclairage l'ensemble cette intervention
poser la question suivante oui ou non
nos pays
je veux dire l'ensemble des pays du
monde sont ils décidés à mobiliser à
l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes leur force de
création leur force d'invention leur
force d'innovation
acceptent-ils d'être simplement les
acheteurs passif de produits fabriqués
par d'autres ou veulent t'ils au
contraire prendre leur destin en main
c'est la question centrale que j'ai
posée à mexico et la question vaut pour
chacun des pays en france même nous
avons entrepris une politique économique
une politique culturelle qui vise à
redonner notre pays beaucoup plus de
vigueur beaucoup plus de santé et ce
qu'on appelle l' impérialisme n'existe
que dans la mesure où les pays les
autres pays l'acceptent et la volonté
que nous exprimons aujourd'hui en france
est de nous battre pour développer notre
économie notre industrie notre
agriculture notre politique culturelle
de manière à être un pays libre et
indépendante de même que et nous prenons
exemple sur le grand pays que sont les
états unis de même que les états unis
cherchent aussi à se développer
économiquement politiquement et
militairement et il n'y a là rien que de
très normal ils ne sont qu'une croisade
c'est un mot très fort une croisade se
fait contre des infidèles
alors vous avez fait appel pour cette
croisade devant une assistance de pays
de représentants du pays du tiers-monde
qui ont déjà tendance au sein de
l'unesco de faire une sorte d'anti
américanisme primaire
il me semble que cela pouvait être pris
comme voulant susciter
arlon de 7,2 cette attitude de cet
esprit alors qu'est ce que vous vouliez
étant donné l'assistance et le cadre le
contexte dans lequel vous avez lancé cet
appel les représentants présents à
mexico était moins ignorant que vous ne
paraissez lettre les représentants des
pays présents et chico savent que
françois mitterrand et l'ensemble du
gouvernement français ont noué avec les
créateurs du monde entier et notamment
les créateurs américains des rapports
d'amitié
vous l'ignorez pas puisque les
américains que les oeuvres de françois
mitterrand sont actuellement publiées
aux états unis est préfacé par le grand
écrivain william styron vous l'ignorez
pas que certains des grands créateurs
américains
je pense en particulier à orson welles
réalisera son prochain film en france
avec le concours de la puissance
publique française et que depuis un an
et demi que je suis au gouvernement
nous avons reconnu sous la forme
d'hommage particulier de grands
cinéastes américains
king vidor du corps et quelques autres
mais ne confondons pas deux choses
il ya d'une part les liens d'amitié
entre les créateurs entre les articles
tous les pays et nous souhaitons quand à
nous très largement développer nos
relations culturelles avec chacun des
pays
un autre témoignage de sept de ses liens
étroits avec les états unis
c'est la présence d'un américain
monsieur negroponte est à la tête du
centre d'informatique que mondiale créée
par monsieur servan-schreiber à la
demande du président de la république
j'ai quelques difficultés ne confondons
pas deux choses d'une part les relations
culturelles et d'autre part les
relations économiques
les etats unis sont combatifs en matière
économique
pourquoi les pays d'europe ne le
serait-il pas justement une
des choses que vous vouliez faire selon
le rapport ça ne sonne je pense que ça
s'applique comme ça c'est de monter avec
une partie de votre budget un centre
pour le livre français à new york un
centre gouvernemental
alors sachant comment travaillent les
éditeurs américains on se demande
comment un organisme d'état peut espérer
de faire acheter par un éditeur
américain un bouquin qu'il n'aurait pas
de tout man de toutes les manières soit
voulu l'acheter parce qu'il était un bon
livre ou bien qui n'intéressent pas du
tout parce que ça n'intéresse pas santé
je me permets de vous interrompre fait
allusion à un rapport qui n'engage que
son auteur et qui ne correspond pas à la
politique actuelle du gouvernement nous
sommes pas assez stupide pour penser que
la politique extérieure de la france en
matière culturelle noie pas s'adapter à
la situation de chaque pays et c'est
bien pourquoi dans différents domaines
nous avons établi des relations avec les
entreprises privées américaines
vous savez l'entreprise gros mot par
exemple a conclu avec columbia une
entreprise américaine un accord pour
assurer la diffusion de films notamment
deux films français aux états unis de
même en ce moment nous préparons avec
les grands magasins vos mines d'ales à
new york deux mois sur la culture
française
mais là encore ce sont des particuliers
des entrepreneurs privés américains qui
en prennent la charge alors ce centre
vous ne faites pas c'est un projet qui a
été proposé il n'est pas question de
créer une structure gouvernementale à
new york
il me semble que vous avez nuancer votre
juge le jugement initial en arrivant au
pouvoir sur le film américain
néanmoins j'aimerais bien vous demandez
est ce que vous pensez on a vu à la télé
cette semaine par exemple un film les
hommes du président est ce qu'un tel
film qui est un critique fondamentale du
gouvernement de la société de la manière
dont elles travaillent et est possible
en france et d'ailleurs j'aimerais
j'aimerais aussi vous poser une autre
question l'iace la tête une seule
question la fois des e mails et c'est la
seule et même question
on parle beaucoup des dallas comme étant
le pire exemple du l'exportation
commercial américain
mais si on y regarde bien il ya une
deuxième lecture possible
c'est peut-être la critique la plus à
chariot et que j'ai jamais vue contre la
société américaine
alors est-ce qu'un feuilleton pareil
est-ce que des films pareils
son possible en france et est ce que ce
n'est pas en fait ce système commercial
du profit qui produit cela aimer effet
que cela soit possible
vous savez en france nous avons un
système de cinéma libre et indépendant
qui reçoit des contributions qui sont
principalement des contributions venant
de l'économie du cinéma
nos cinéastes sont aussi corrosif est
libre de comportement que les cinéastes
américains mais je n'ai pas l'intention
d'opposer une cinématographie à l'autre
personnellement nous faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai jamais dit j'adore le cinéma
américain
j'aime les cinéastes américains et je
leur ai rendu hommage alors s'il vous
plaît cessons d'organiser de faux procès
je souhaite au contraire que le public
français connaissent les meilleurs films
américains et ils peuvent sur notre
territoire entre et sans aucune
restriction
mais no contest n'est pas toujours vrai
les films français n'ont pas le même
accès sur le territoire américain
vous accuser de protectionnisme alors
que nous sommes largement ouvert vers
l'atlantique
ouvrez largement vos portes aux états
unis au film français mais je pense que
comme vous le savez s'ils sont bons si
sts quand les livres français sont bons
quand les films français sont bons les
américains sont les premiers à vouloir
les voulait dire les voir bien sûr est
actuellement même aux états unis
certains films français ont tu as un
grand succès je pense notamment à diva
il ya un autre projet dont on a parlé
qui m'a intrigué
c'était eux quand le président
mitterrand a été à budapest en hongrie
il a dit aux hongrois très amicalement
qui voudraient faire en sorte que une
quinzaine de livres
ambroise soit traduite et publiée en
france et alors il semblerait que les
semaines les maisons d'édition française
n'arrive pas à trouver
des bouquins qui pour eux valent la
peine d'être publié alors il me semble
que c est ce que ce n'est pas le genre
de dirigisme culturelle qui fait ce qui
fait poser par exemple monsieur de
virieu des questions telles que à quoi
sert un ministère de la culture
mais les relations culturelles
internationales sont souvent conduites
par les gouvernements et par les états
les professionnels de l'édition
française contrairement à ce que vous
dites savent parfaitement que nous avons
besoin en france de faire traduire
davantage d'auteurs étrangers
certaines maisons s'y emploie il n'est
pas normal que la littérature hongroise
soit si mal connu en france et le petit
coup de main que nous voulons apporter
pour faire connaître les auteurs
hongrois ne bénéficiera pas seulement
aux auteurs hongrois nous étions en inde
avec le président de la république
voici trois semaines la même décision a
été prise au bénéfice de romancier
indien encore trop peu connue en france
nous avons une conception des relations
internationales qui sont pas seulement
en termes d'expansion vers l'extérieur
mais aussi en terme d'accueil en france
des écrivains des réalisateurs et des
créateurs étrangers
ça c'est les provinces détail temps
alors je crois que svp veut intervenir
harrouard une question oui simplement
vous travaillez dallas tout à l'heure
les téléspectateurs qui suivent votre
conversation veut savoir si vous
regardez dallas et si vous aimez dallas
il m'est arrivé il m'arrive parfois de
regarder dallas et dallas comme
l'indiqué notre ami journaliste
américain contrairement aux apparences
est une série qui ne manque pas de
cruauté et d'esprit de corrosif sur la
vie américaine dont la réponse à la
question posée
j'ai une autre question monsieur le
ministre alors qu'ils changent du tout
au tout c'est un net comptable de thiais
qui nous dit quelle culture avez vous
apporté depuis un an et demi aux
banlieusards smicards c'est une bonne
question
c'est une bonne question et c'est vrai
que nous ne pouvons pas en quelques mois
changer la situation c'est vrai que
notre pays et est divisée en classes
sociales ça existe et qu en particulier
dans les zones périphériques des villes
il ya une situation notamment pour les
jeunes extrêmement difficile quels
changements nous avons apporté déjà deux
premiers changements nous évoquions un
instant le cinéma que vous savez
peut-être la plupart des salles de
cinéma ne se trouve que dans les centres
des grandes villes est une décision
prise par nous voici un an consiste à
aider des municipalités de communes
périphériques a créé les salles de
cinéma
j'étais voici trois semaines à epinay et
j'ai constaté avec joie que cette ville
qui avait été privé de cinéma pendant
cinq ans a pu aider à la naissance d'un
complexe cinéma qui je crois ne
désemplit pas depuis son ouverture
voilà un exemple que vaine
l'autre question j'étais fasciné par les
dernières de m'excuser je le dis lit
rapidement une note de votre ministère
disons en mai 81 les français ont choisi
de changement ils ont émis un vote
culturel avec françois mitterrand la
dimension culturelle aérien investi le
débat politique la culture est au centre
de la politique menée depuis 18 mois
alors ça soulève en deux mois la
réflexion est ce que ce n'est pas une
sorte de conception grains de chiens
de la culture la culture c'est la
politique pour capter le pouvoir il faut
d'abord capté capter la culture alors
maintenant que vous êtes au pouvoir
est-ce que vous pensez que le parti
socialiste doit avoir une politique de
2,2 pour prendre un pour garder et
conquérir la culture pour pouvoir garder
le pouvoir politique
mais ce sont là des histoires que avant
de toutes pièces je lis ici ou là que
nous voudrions nous emparer les esprits
depuis que nous sommes là jamais il ya
eu un tel climat de liberté et puisque
vous êtes en france monsieur avec nous
fait l'honneur d'être avec nous ce soir
je dirais que depuis l'arrivée de
françois mitterrand la présidence de la
république il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'artistes étrangers venant vivre en
france et je pourrais vous citer des
dizaines d'exemples
tout à l'heure je parlais d'orson welles
je pourrais aussi vous parler du
cinéaste polonais wajda dont le récent
film dernier film a été réalisé en
france avec des capitaux français le
cinéaste turc güney dont le dernier film
se tourne à ce moment même en france le
cinéaste géorgien aussi liany et tant
d'autres et nous les artistes et
créateurs ont choisi notre pays parce
que notre pays aujourd'hui renoue avec
la grande tradition de liberté
ils savent qu'ils peuvent trouver à
paris en france un climat de
tranquillité de liberté largement
ouverts à la tolérance
est-ce que vous pensez que la culture
est un moyen de conquête de pouvoir
politique mais nous sommes des hommes en
chair et en os avec un esprit
la culture c'est prendre conscience du
monde c'est essayer de le comprendre et
de le changer et nous croyons oui à
l'importance des forces de l'esprit sur
la matière
nous pensons en effet que aujourd'hui à
la fin de ce siècle
ce sont les forces de les prix je veux
dire chacun d'entre nous citoyens libres
qui pouvons changer la société et
l'améliorer bon monsieur le ministre
deuxième interlocuteur vous choisissez
monsieur jean françois lacan du journal
le monde
alors j'en pense à lacan du monde une
question svp pendant que lacan
s'installe
absolument il ya énormément de questions
ce soir trouvez-vous raisonnable
d'engager des grandes dépenses dans des
projets comme la villette où l'opéra de
la bastille en période de crise
et cet effort culturel sera t-il
poursuivi c'est une question qui nous
ont souvent posé sa part la villette
faut peut-être rappeler d'abord ce que
c'est que tout le monde ne le sait pas
oui je crois qu'il faut peut être
rappeler aux sites et des sirops
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent que
la décision était prise de réaliser en
france
à ce nombre de grands équipements la
ville est le plus grand parc de paris
accueillera la fois une cité des
sciences est une cité de la musique
il a été décidé aussi de créer à l'opéra
de construire à la bastille pardon un
opéra populaire et moderne
et puis surtout la décision a été prise
approuvée hier par la conférence des
expositions universelles d'organiser à
paris en 1989
l'exposition universelle depuis 1900 il
n'y a pas eu en france d'exposition
universelle
alors je réponds à la question des
téléspectateurs par une observation que
très souvent le président de la
république a eu l'occasion de faire
rappelez vous rappelez vous la france de
1870 un pays vaincu un pays qui sortait
déchiré de la commune et de la
répression versaillaise un pays dans le
doute un certain entre la république et
la monarchie et cette france-là cette
france de 1870 a pris la décision
d'organiser la première exposition
universelle
d'après la guerre croyez vous que notre
pays un siècle après éduquer former
plein de force n'est pas capable de
faire la même chose
nous pensons que un pays comme la france
doit se fixer quelques grand objectif
mobilisateur et l'exposition universelle
2009 sera l'occasion pour
les artisans les industriels les
créateurs du pays de montrer leurs
capacités et leur invention
on sera prêt on sera prêt je l'espère
alors là quand première question il ya
un projet vous avez boulot qu'est
monsieur ministre celui d'une maison de
la presse
si bien que c'est un projet qui avait
été décidée par monsieur giscard
d'estaing une maison là mais ce que j'ai
trouvé au grand palais et abriter les
journalistes internationaux et vous
n'avez pas jugée recevable ce projet
n'est pas bloqué ce qui est bloqué c'est
l'installation de ces deux ans après ce
au grand palais contrairement à ce qu'on
peut penser
paris capitale du pays ne dispose pas au
coeur de la ville d' espace libre pour
cabre accueillir de grandes
manifestations
nous avons pensé qu'il n'était pas bien
de mobiliser ce grand espace pour y
faire des bureaux en revanche est en
liaison avec l'exposition universelle
la décision a été prise de construire à
paris un grand centre de conférences
internationales ou la maison de la
presse aura son abri très bien moi je
voulais vous parler de la télévision de
l'audiovisuel c'est étonnant puisque la
première question de téléspectateurs a
porté là dessus c'est normal c'est
normal je croyais que les débats du
gouvernement actuellement porte là
dessus on est plein à une charnière des
changements et puis si on regarde en
fait les le document qui a sorti votre
ministère n'y a pas longtemps sur les
pratiques culturelles des français on
s'aperçoit que depuis dix ans les
français passent quasi totalité de leur
temps libre à l'écouté des machines
culturel radio télévision chaîne hifi
magnétoscope bientôt micro-ordinateurs
aussi est ce si effectivement au
détriment de la fréquentation des
institutions culturelles
malgré tous les efforts des ministères
de la culture précédent et du vôtre la
fréquentation de l'opéra des musées elle
est en petite progression mais elle
reste aux alentours de 10%
elle touche 10% de la population
française alors et que les gestes
intéressants parce que moi j'ai des
chiffres là sous les yeux mais je vous
parlais effectivement et c'est donc une
publication qui sort ces jours-ci la
chez dalloz
on voit 2% opéra 2% opérette 5% ballet
7% concert grande musique 9% meeting
politique défilé 90% télévision 85
pour sa radio etc les chiffres les
chiffres sont énormes qui les parlent en
tout cas que c'est de vous interrompre
un instant ces chiffres sont comme tous
les chiffres il faut les éclairer oui
c'est justement je dirais s'agissant
alors delà du phénomène de sortie des
gens en dehors de chez eux
je crois que l'anc est que nous avons
demandé fait apparaître que les français
aujourd'hui ont davantage envie de se
retrouver entre amis en famille de
sortir
j'ajoute que si vous rapportez ces
chiffres à l'évolution depuis deux ans
on constate que les salles de spectacles
sont beaucoup plus fréquentes et qu'il
ya deux ans sans parler du cinéma alors
qu'il connaît c'est un phénomène
exceptionnel en europe qui connaît des
hausses de fréquentation très
remarquable la fréquentation du cinéma a
augmenté de plus de 25% en deux ans oui
c'est tout à fait exact est néanmoins
vous ne pouvez pas nier qu'il ya une
espèce de mutations dans les veines dans
les pratiques culturelles des français
ils ont par rapport au spectacle vivant
sont aujourd'hui une série de spectacles
en boîte de culture à domicile et
premier défi comment vous qui êtes à la
fois ministre a culture mais aussi exact
de théâtre homme de spectacle
comment vous réagissez comme on vous
analysé cette mutation culturelle
je crois que il faut là encore ne pas se
contenter de rester a déjà mis la
situation actuelle il faut regarder un
peu l'avenir et les changements qui vont
se produire et à cet égard si vous me
permettez cette parenthèse je crois que
beaucoup de choses ne peuvent se
comprendre et de l'économie et de la
politique et de la crise que l'ensemble
des pays industrialisés connaissent si
on ne se rappelle pas qu'en ce moment
même se produit un bouleversement
technologique sans précédent
je veux dire que la robotisation
l'informatisation va transformer
transforme déjà notre mode de vie et de
deux manières
premièrement en libérant du temps et du
temps pour les loisirs l'application et
deuxièmement en modifiant le travail
lui-même qui sera de plus en plus libéré
des tâches physiques et de plus orienté
vers les tâches intellectuelles
ce qui me permet de dire que dans la
période qui s'ouvre
les activités de l'esprit l'éducation
l'information la télévision
le cinéma le théâtre la musique tout ce
qui est relatif à la rrq et de l'esprit
va connaître dans les prochaines années
un développement considérable et on peut
expliquer que si notre pays veut gagner
la bataille économique
il doit en même temps dès maintenant
décidé d'investir dans les industries de
la culture est l'avenir pour les pays
industrialisés comme pour les autres ce
sont les industries de la culture et par
rapport à la question vous posiez la
télévision est ce qui fait qu'on a des
atouts particuliers première fois une
révolution industrielle démarre partout
dans le monde à la fois les atouts très
importants pour la france et je crois
qu'il faut l'expliquer en quelques mots
d'abord si vous permettez une première
décision a été prise par le gouvernement
c'est une décision historique qu aucun
autre pays n'a prise elle a été prise il
ya un mois
elle consiste à décider d'investir dans
les câbles en fibre optique qui vont
alimenter l'ensemble du pays en nouveau
réseau une affaire importante comme l'a
été disons le choix du téléphone il ya
quelques années tout un premier choix
c'est une décision risque aussi lorsque
ça multiplie les mécanos où est ce qu'on
va pouvoir faire face à ces quarante ou
cinquante ou soixante cannes ou de
réseaux locaux grand investissement
industriel comporte une part de risque
le tgv s'était risqué aussi et quand la
france a décidé d'investir dans des
industries de demain et n'a pas eu à le
regretter mais ça ne suffirait pas c'est
vrai il faut quand même préciser pour
compléter ce que dit lacan que ça ouvre
la possibilité et multiplicité probable
est que peut-être ces programmes nous ne
serons pas capables de les fournir
alors c'est la tristesse votre domaine
c'est la question que les raisons
plaçons-nous en 1800 1990 pardon
imaginons nos enfants ils auront à leur
disposition
10-15 boutons des petites machines sur
lesquelles appuyé et la question qui se
pose
nous allons la poser monsieur de virieu
est la suivante lorsque ses enfants
appuierons sur ses boutons est ce qu'au
rendez vous ils trouveront le même
programme stéréotypé ou est-ce qu'au
contraire il y aura une prodigieuse
diversité d'image
peut-être se poser d'abord la question
est-ce qu'ils auront envie d'appuyer est
ce qu'on connaît le marché est ce qu'on
sait ce qu'il ya derrière
dans l'hôtel des gens mais c'est là
qu'en national comme l'indiqué l'instant
le besoin d'image est un besoin
important et on voit déjà aux états unis
un phénomène se produire ou il y a
pénurie d'image les réseaux sont
multipliés à l'infini aux états unis est
pour l'instant la production n'a pas
suivi vient il y à un désaccord entre la
surabondance des réseaux et la pénurie
des images et comme notre pays est par
tradition et parce que nous voulons
aujourd'hui un pays créatif un pays
inventif avec des artistes des
inventeurs de toutes sortes
un cinéma prospère un théâtre je crois
l'un des meilleurs d'europe
nos chances sont grandes pour préparer
une industrie notre patrimoine notre
patrimoine en effet nos chances sont
grandes pour préparer une industrie des
programmes pour nous mêmes d'abord et
pour les vendre aux autres ensuite je
crois que les français peuvent être
sensibles à ce type d'arguments mais la
wii ne comprennent plus c'est quand les
pouvoirs publics d'un côté et lance une
offensive sur un modèle de déploiement
du visuel original et ambitieux et que
d'un autre côté sur un phénomène qui
connaissent bien tu es celui de la vidéo
et du magnétoscope on voit prendre des
décisions apparemment assez aberrant
voilà un outil culturel puisqu'il permet
d'avoir une attitude assez sélectif par
rapport à la télévision parce qu'il
permet de diffuser aussi le cinéma de
manière très large et voilà qu'on le
taxe une redevance qu'on me taxe à une
tva à prendre 3 % ceux ci dessus qu'on
les stops à poitiers alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
parce que c'est une contradiction vous
êtes resté bien discret sur cette
affaire de la vidéo je peux vous
répondre très directement est très
simplement
d'abord je m'étonne que ce pas vous
mêmes que ceux qui aujourd'hui se
scandalise de cette redevance ne se soit
pas plutôt scandalisé il y a quelques
années de l'absence de décision
française pour se fabriquer une
industrie nationale du magnétoscope
celui mans votre prédécesseur trouvez
vous normal de gars normal et le parle
pas seulement pour la france mais
beaucoup d'autres pays doit vous normal
que aujourd'hui les japonais soit
quasiment les seuls producteurs
90% à monopole le resto néerlandais mais
c'est inquiétant la diversification là
encore est une nécessité dans la
première réponse
deuxième réponse les allusions à la
redevance je crois que il est tout à
fait essentiel que chacun n'oublie pas
que les artistes ce qu'ils font c'est
beau programme que nous regardons
ensemble ou isolément les artistes ont
besoin de vivre je veux dire qu'ils ne
vivent pas seulement d'amour et d'eau
fraîche
il faut par conséquent rémunérer la
création
rémunérer la production cette année
il fallait bien que quelqu'un paye la
télévision de 1983 vouliez-vous que ce
soit le budget non car nous voulions
faire un effort de rigueur
vouliez-vous que ce soit la redevance
non pas nous ne voulions pas pénaliser
des millions de téléspectateurs
vouliez-vous que sur la publicité non
car nous ne voulions pas pénaliser la
presse il restait alors en effet cette
nuit d'une redevance sur les
magnétoscopes et je ne vois pas là
matière à se scandaliser et je dirais
même pour avoir jadis dans mon précédent
métier enseigné le droit fiscal et le
droit budgétaire que généralement quand
on veut décider d'un prélèvement nouveau
on ne l'a soit pas sur une industrie en
déclin mais sur une industrie en
développement
je pourrais vous répondre monsieur lacan
que la redevance sur interscope séleucie
non pas d'une pénalisation mais d'une
confiance que le gouvernement a dans le
développement des futures technologies
et mieux intervenir
play wifi les prix justement sur ce
problème nous avons énormément de
questions sur le problème ce que coûte
la culture à chaque français alors on
vous dit monsieur lang avec votre loi
sur le prix des livres on ne peut plus
en acheter c'est ce que nous dit un
retraité de paris monsieur lang se
plaint de la mévente des livres alors
qu'il a interdit les 20% de réduction
sur les livres dans les grandes surfaces
et puis on nous dit aussi j'ai
énormément de questions là dessus
pourquoi la tva sur le disque est en
fait un objet de culture est au taux de
33 83 %
c'est donc réservé aux produits de luxe
mais parce que ça veut dire c'est la
culture cher avec vous je vais essayer
de répondre à chacune des questions
posées pour le livre et sans fatigue et
les téléspectateurs temps des questions
des développements trop technique
je dirais que pour le livre comme pour
tout autre secteur culturel la
concentration tue la création la
concentration tue l'esprit d'initiative
et si nous n'avions pas voter cette loi
où j'ai voté cette loi
sorti tard il dit petit à petit les
libraires auraient disparu les points de
ventes se seraient concentrées dans
quelques centres urbains et au bout de
quelques années la création littéraire
en aurait suivi les conséquences et
notre préoccupation l inverse n est que
dans chaque commune de france
chaque citoyen français puisse avoir à
sa disposition
pas trop loin de chez lui si possible
une librairie en tout cas une
bibliothèque est un aspect important
notre politique la création d'un vaste
réseau de lecture publique qui sera je
l'espère l'un des plus modernes d'europe
peut d'ici quelques années et en même
temps de savo risée la création
littéraire le prix des livres le prix
des livres si vous permet de donner une
information le prix des livres
contrairement à ce qui était dit n'a pas
augmenté plus vite que l'inflation se
maintenant ma communauté un chiffre sur
le prix des livres en octobre
il n'a augmenté de 0 3%
par conséquent moins que l'inflation est
ce que votre corps est efficace parce
que finalement on voit se créer partout
des des associations qui permettent de
tourner et finalement le prix le prix
unique du livre est pratiqué des
ristournes
oui mais nous avons dès le départ admise
attaquer et la loi et le moment ça ne
décourage pas d'abord monsieur leclerc
continue dans ses supermarchés a
impliqué des abattements
vous avez des coopératives qui se créent
vous avez en fait tout un la loi et
tourné par plein de la place tu ce dans
l'ensemble elle est dans l'ensemble les
respecter mais je vous indique puisque
vous m'interrogez sur ce point que très
bientôt une mesure sera prise qui
assurera la pleine application de la loi
cette loi a été votée à l'unanimité par
les deux assemblées
toutes tendances confondues elle a été
demandée par lançant des éditeurs
l'ensemble des écrivains lançant des
libraires pas question que cette voie ne
soit pas appliquée et nous prenons en ce
moment même les mesures pour qu'elle
soit appliquée c'est une loi qui est
favorable aux lecteurs est favorable à
la création littéraire revenir aux
ministres à votre affirmation principal
qui me semble très importante bolide
investir dans la culture investir et en
particulier dans les programmes
audiovisuels c'est une priorité
économique
cette affirmation grave période de crise
alors ma question c'est où sont les
entreprises que vous appelez de vos
voeux qu'elle emploie finalement tout
cela va créer ou est ce qu'on va trouver
les financements quelles sont les
banques qui vont se poser ce problème je
dis 'comment est-ce que la chose à
prendre corps je pourrais si vous voulez
vous donner quelques exemples concrets
je crois que c'est la meilleure réponse
est d'abord dire que cette renaissance
économique dont nous parlons à l'instant
naîtra en effet vous avez raison d'une
alliance entre la puissance publique qui
a cette volonté de réanimation
l'économie
les industriels sans lesquels ne pouvons
pas en effet espérer ce redémarrage et
les créateurs je veux dire les hommes
d'invention les chercheurs et artistes
prenons un exemple concret le meuble
trouve-t-on normal que notre pays qui a
le jeu croît le plus important massif
forestier d'europe
excellent qui est la moitié de la
surface de parts de marché oui exporte
ses forêts pour les réimporter sous
forme de meubles
ce qui naturellement se traduit par une
hémorragie de devises insupportable eh
bien nous avons agi pour faire face à
cette situation un concours
international a été ouvert faisant appel
à tous les talents à tous les créateurs
de meubles français ou étrangers de
meubles de bureaux non de up de bureau
nous avons dans un premier temps choisi
de nous axer sur les meubles de bureau
un jury international choisira les
lauréats au début de l'année prochaine
des alliances seront noués avec des
industriels qui par avance ont accepté
de faire travailler ses créateurs et
enfin plusieurs ministères et
administrations ont accepté d'acheter
ses futurs meubles un exemple avec
d'encre et notre quelqu'un me dise en
exemple pour le futur ministère des
finances c'est le plus riche évidemment
ce n'est pas le moment au moment où il
quittera le louvre mouvement quittera le
de mollo la moiti la moitié des
immeubles du futur ministre des finances
sera alimentée par ce processus
mais je pourrais vous prendre les
créateurs étrangers
français françaises ou étrangers le jury
le décidera mais comme vous savez les
grandes périodes de l'histoire de france
sur le plan culturel ont été marqués par
l'entremêlement d'artistes français et
d'artistes étrangers
vous pourrez prendre d'autres exemples
songez que l'inventeur de la machine à
photo composé est un français qui a
immigré aux états unis voici trente ans
la france par tradition à l'école
d'artistes créateurs de l'être tout à
fait remarquable mais que nous n'avons
plus de machines françaises
les inventeurs sont bloqués ne peuvent
plus faire avancer leur art
nous avons décidé de proposer à cet
inventeur de revenir en france
j'espère que très bientôt une machine à
photo composé française verra le jour
il a accepté il a accepté tout à l'heure
nous avons ensemble juste avant
l'émission
nous avons vu un extrait du film 30
mairie les américains ont mis au point
un système de synthèse par ordinateur
qui permet de fabriquer les dessins
animés par ordinateur
système d'avenir qui permettra de
fabriquer dans de bonnes conditions
les films d'animation que jadis ont déjà
fabriqué à la main comme vous l'avez vu
l'un des créateurs du film le
dessinateur du film est un français
comment ne l'a pas vue aussi si on l'a
vu dans les mesures prévues mais si je
les ai vus j'ai vu on a interviewé mieux
pieusse mes vieux c'est un des grands
dessinateurs français et l'école
français de bande dessinée est une des
meilleures du monde
voilà une situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons on pourra bientôt venir
faire éclore avec monsieur chevènement
vaillant et monsieur 6 juillet nous
avons décidé de mettre au point en effet
un plan pour la création d'un système
français de fabrication de synthèse
d'image ulysse 31 ministres en terre que
beaucoup de jeunes aiment à la
télévision sait-on que les images ont
été inventés par des français mais ils
sont fabriqués par des japonais
alors nous voulons mettre un terme à
cette dépendance et nous voulons
constituer une industrie nationale des
programmes et une industrie tout
derniers interlocuteurs mais ses
ministres et leurs pendants et il vient
s'installer au début dit d'abord son nom
monsieur jean d'ormesson du figaro
magazine et et j'ajoute de l'académie
française 2 0 alors de troisième appel
svp est-ce que vous avez des questions
des biens pendant que monsieur
d'ormesson s'installe un téléspectateur
de paris vous demande est il nécessaire
d'être cultivé pour être ministre de la
culture
et ce quelles réponses
en tout cas on peut on peut revendiquer
le droit à l'ignorance et je le
revendique
et depuis que j'ai la chance et la
charge d'être à la tête du ministère la
culture chaque jour je mesure l'étendue
de mon ignorance
alors jean d'ormesson bonjour monsieur
ministre bon je voudrais reprendre mais
en l'approfondissant un peu et en la
personnalisant la question de monsieur
de virieu est ce qu'un ministre la
culture sert à quelque chose
le poste qui n'existe pas dans la
plupart des démocraties occidentales
mais qui existe dans les pays de l'est a
été taillée sur mesure pour un écrivain
hors mesures auxquelles personne je
crois peut-être même pas vous même ce
ministre ne peut être comparé andré
malraux mais il semble bien que ce poste
n'appartiennent pas vraiment à la
tradition républicaine
je reviens d'un pays que vous allez
reconnaître tout de suite parce que rien
de ce qui concerne la plus
internationale de vous êtes étranger où
il existe un ministre de l'intelligence
ou les huiles a gelé reçu cet après midi
au ministère de la culture
vous voyez et être cultivée et bien
est-ce que ministre la culture ce n'est
pas aussi surprenant que d'être ministre
de l'intelligence est ce qu'il n'ya pas
antinomie entre la notion de culture et
la notion ministre la remarque
naturellement s'applique à tous les
ministres de la culture mais surtout à
vous parce que quelqu'un a écrit en 1978
tout pouvoir se nourrit d'arbitraire et
organise sa propre tranquillité la
culture et révolte défi ou n'est rien
bravo ce quelqu'un naturellement sévit
alors vous vous demandez c'est cette
formule ne vaut que quand vous êtes dans
l'opposition
et si elle devient caduque dès que vous
êtes au pouvoir
ou est ce que par hasard vous sauriez le
ministre de rien
je voudrais essayer de répondre très
concrètement à la question de monsieur
d'ormesson
c'est une bonne question à quoi bon un
ministère de la culture
je dirais pour être le plus simple
possible pour aider à l'accomplissement
de deux fonctions il ya d'abord une
première fonction que tout gouvernement
doit assumer
je pense que vous pouvez y être sensible
vous qui vous intéressait au patrimoine
c'est la préservation de notre
patrimoine et patrimoine en france
considérable quand vous pensez par
exemple que ces prêts de 38000 monument
protégé auquel il faut veiller
quand vous pensez que nous parlons de
cinéma c'est 72 mille films qu'il faut
restaurer un million de clichés
photographiques qu'il faut remettre en
état et quand je suis arrivée rue de
valois mini-serre la culture il y avait
sous mon bureau entassés dans la
poussière
toutes les oeuvres de nadar le
patrimoine c'est le patrimoine de nos
traditions c'est le patrimoine des
pierres c'est beaucoup encore ses 10000
org en france et condition d'entretenir
et combien de rédacteurs des ordres pour
les entretenir
malheureusement trop peu de tf1 alors
ils montrent peu une quarantaine et je
pourrais prendre beaucoup de causes
exactes quand vous pensez monsieur
d'ormesson que la cathédrale de
strasbourg depuis un demi siècle est
enserrée par des échafaudages et que le
public ne peut en voir en partant
particulier la partie occidentale grâce
à la politique nouvelle je pense
qu'avant la fin de l'année prochaine on
pourra re découvrir
c'est dégradant sa splendeur quand vous
pensez que la cathédrale de toul abîmé
en 1114 rend la guerre à bignan les 145
n'a pas encore été restauré alors un
ministère de la culture
déjà pour garder pour les générations
futures
ce patrimoine ce patrimoine tout à
l'heure
monsieur vers le faisait observer ce
patrimoine qui est pour nous français un
gisement culturel exceptionnel
je prends un exemple le mont saint
michel 2 millions de visiteurs par an
six gardiens et en même temps une
richesse extraordinaire et nous avons
décidé de faire une première expérience
c'est en liaison avec les questions pour
jeter leurs armes et cela quand une
expérience qui consistera à installer
pour les visiteurs un système vidéo
disque recueillant 200000 donnait sur
l'histoire de l'architecturé du
moyen-âge sur l'histoire du lieu et qui
permettront aux visiteurs de mieux
s'informer sur notre patrimoine national
à ministère la culture ce n'est pas
seulement pour veiller au passé c'est
aussi pour essayer d'ouvrir les voies de
l'avenir
non pas en cherchant à imposer ses vues
mais au contraire en ayant comme
principe donner ses chances à chacun
multiplier les chances de la création
d'abord en préparant les jeunes
notamment les enfants à l'éducation
artistique est ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'un siècle après jules ferry
des millions d'enfants français des
millions soit encore privés aujourd'hui
du droit à l'éducation artistique
je trouve ce n'est pas normal et de même
que à la fin du iième siècle on a créé
l'école
je crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui
permettre à chaque jeune français qui le
veut qu'il veut apprendre s'il le
souhaite un instrument de musique le
dessin la poésie etc
voilà à quoi ça sert un ministère la
culture ça sert aussi à permettre à
notre cinéma national d'être un cinéma
toujours plus vivant toujours plus
créatif ça sert notamment à permettre à
tous les français quelle que soit la
commune où ils habitent
petites ou grandes communes d'avoir à
leur disposition
pas trop loin de chez eux une salle de
cinéma une bibliothèque un champ de
cultures
bref de quoi alimenter leurs loisirs
mais ne faites pas croire que cette
politique là suppose
qu'on veuille exercer je sais quelle
dictature spirituelle car depuis que
nous sommes arrivés nous avons largement
ouvert les portes à toutes les familles
de pensée et je souhaite même si vous le
désirez que vous fournissez un exemple
qui témoigne du contraire
eh bien monsieur le ministre je crains
pour vous que vous ne soyez charmant
comme moi et croyez-moi ce n'est pas
très bon signe
en vous écoutant vous sauvez passé vous
sauver l'avenir
personne ne doit être exclue la culture
c'est nous tous la culture c'est moi les
grilles sont levés on a l'impression
qu'on sort d'un tunnel et qu'on entre en
vendra beaucoup à faire
lyon 9 heures et voilà et notre ami
américain tout à l'heure avait cité la
phrase la dimension culturelle a
réinvesti le débat politique
alors moi je me demande quelquefois si
vous me demandez un exemple si
quelquefois ce n'est pas avec vous le
débat politique qui a investi la
dimension culturelle
je vous pose cette question parce qu'il
me semble et je vous prie m'interrompre
si mes citations sont faux ce que vous
opposiez deux cultures la culture de
droite et la culture de gauche je crois
que vous avez écrit dans le matin en
1978 la culture est un terrain qui
appartient à la gauche celui de
l'intelligence de la création et de
l'imagination et dans une formule d'un
manichéisme assez stupéfiant qu'aucun de
vos prédécesseurs n'aurait osé formuler
en l'adaptant à ses vues et que pour ma
part je ne reprendrais certainement pas
même en la retournant
vous avez dit votre journal dans la
tolérance même et vous avez parlé de
cette frontière que nous avons franchi
ce n'est pas moi monsieur ménisque en
interroge chez vous vous avez parlé de
cette frontière que nous avons franchi
le 10 mai et qui sépare la nuit de
l'aide l'ue met en effet en effet la
question
dans votre discours en effet la police
la nuit
c est ce que vous êtes un ministre
socialiste de la culture
ou est-ce que vous êtes plutôt un
ministre de la culture socialiste comme
à l'accoutumée vous est brillant et cinq
aux heures
non je me suis mis c'est vous qui l'êtes
desservant le ministre mais ce qui est
important ce sont bien sûr les
déclarations et je m'en expliquer mais
ce qui est important ce sont les actes
et depuis 18 mois croyez moi nous
n'avons pas chômé et personne ne niera
l'évidence même s'il ya encore beaucoup
à faire il ya beaucoup à faire beaucoup
a changé déjà et le paysage culture de
la france est déjà beaucoup transformée
en tout cas confiance a été donnée à la
plupart des créateurs français et le
propos de moi que vous citiez à
l'instant signifier qu en effet jamais
aucun gouvernement dans le passé n'a
bénéficié d'un tel assentiment de la
part des créateurs des inventeurs
français voyez l'immense succès des
assises organisées par jean pierre
chevènement sur la recherche
scientifique des milliers de chercheurs
et d'inventeurs qui pendant des mois et
des mois
on réfléchit ensemble pour proposer au
gouvernement une nouvelle politique la
recherche et voiliers de quelle manière
la plupart des réformes qu au nom du
gouvernement j'ai proposé pour le cinéma
pour le théâtre pour la musique pour la
littérature ont recueilli l'assentiment
de la plupart des créateurs car chacun
sent bien que la maison me serre la
culture c'est la maison de chacun et que
chacun ya sa place et je vous mets au
défi de citer un quelconque exemple de
quelqu'un qui ait pu être évincé ce
ministère en raison des opinions
politiques
tout au contraire et voyez ce soir près
de nous à présent des hommes et des
femmes de toutes opinions publiques et
politiques qui assument des fonctions
importantes dans le domaine de la
culture des amis d'autres pays
notre ami giorgio strehler qui accepte
t ce qu'il avait refusé aux
gouvernements précédents qui a accepté
de diriger à nos des eaux le théâtre de
l'europe ou encore notre ami costa
gavras cinéaste qui a pris en main la
cinémathèque française pour en faire une
institution important sur le plan
international je vous mets au défi
michée formation de citer un quelconque
exemple qui puisse montrer que ce
gouvernement est intolérant ce
gouvernement au contraire a témoigné
exprimé un sens de la liberté que nos
prédécesseurs auraient pu avant la
lettre suivre alors que le gouvernement
vous avez enfin le précédent en france
74 avait été nommé quand même au théâtre
de chaillot c'est donc lui aussi qu'on
avait reconnu la priorité de votre
talent sur votre engagement politique
oui mais vous n'ignorez pas que quelques
semaines après l'élection monsieur
giscard d'estaing je le sais je fut
chassé par un homme qu à peine nommé moi
même ministre de la culture j'ai
confirmé dans ses fonctions et lui
apporter cette énorme d'ailleurs car ce
jeune homme de grand talent les moyens
nécessaires pour son travail
vous ne croyez plus alors qu'à culturel
champ réservé de la gauche
comme dirait que je veux dire que comme
la gauche en effet crois que notre
société notre pays peut se transformer
par la force de la volonté par la force
de l'invention par la force de l'esprit
les hommes de culture de science se
reconnaissent tout naturellement à
travers le gouvernement de la gauche et
vous le verrez nous organisons la au
mois de février prochain une grande
réunion internationale où les plus
grands créateurs du monde entier seront
présents
non pas qu'ils approuvent à 100% la
politique du gouvernement français mais
ils se reconnaissent à travers elle
alors vous parlez de l'assentiment des
créateurs des artistes les écrivains des
intellectuels alors je voulais m'appuyer
sur le témoignage de deux intellectuels
je crois au dessus de toute contestation
de professeur au collège de france et
que vous ne resterez peut-être pas dans
nos gènes la zone je n'écoute personne
c'est ça contrairement à vous je ne
rejette personne contrairement à votre
profession de foi la france de françois
mitterrand n'a pas de leçon à recevoir
de quelques intellectuels qui ont refusé
le 10 mai donc nous on enregistre est
peut-être passé de là le premier sert et
moir lorsque les porte parole du
gouvernement traite des questions
culturelles
il éveille plus ironique que la tante et
la deuxième c'est emmanuel le roy
ladurie la représentativité de langues
en ce qui concerne la population
intellectuelle devient problématique
alors ce que je voulais vous demander c
est ce que vous croyez que vous avez
fait tout ce qu'il faut et en actions et
en paroles pour que les forces culturel
de ce pays si divers
si complexe et parfois s'ils divisent et
se reconnaissent en fait on ne fait
jamais complètement tout ce qu'il faut
il faudrait faire mieux encore qu'on le
fait mais je crois que je le répète dans
tous les domaines de la création cinéma
peinture musique sculpture littérature
je la firme la majorité des hommes de
création se reconnaissent en effet à
travers ce gouvernement ce qui ne veut
pas dire ne faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai jamais dit que nous souhaitions
enrôler les hommes de création et la
culture
nous sommes en démocratie et chacun est
libre de ses opinions et je précise que
même ceux qui ne partage pas l'opinion
du classement sont accueillis mais ça la
culture et j'ai confié des tâches
importantes à des hommes qui
n'appartiennent pas à la famille de la
majorité actuelle
voyez par exemple les hommes thomas les
hommes qui se sont vu confier la
direction des grandes opérations dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure à la tête
de l'exposition universelle c'est
monsieur robert bordage auquel le
président pompidou avait confié la
création du centre beaubourg à la tête
de du musée d'orsay c'est monsieur
jacques rigaud qui fut jadis directeur
du cabinet de jeu
djamel à la tête de l'opéra de la
bastille c'est monsieur bloch lainé un
grand serviteur de l'état à la tête de
la cité de la villette c'est monsieur de
l'ouvrier un homme qui a servi sous les
anciens gouvernements qui naturellement
et le royal comme il doit l'être à
l'égard de ce gouvernement
vraiment j'attends de vous que vous
citiez les exemples d'intolérance ils
sont dans votre esprit
et malheureusement l'opposition depuis
lé depuis 18 mois
essaye de se fabriquer les épouvantails
à moineaux de ce qu'on vit mal elle
invente et l'imaginent ne manquent pas
d'imagination ce qu'il trouve
quelquefois seul mini cd contradictions
par exemple en soixante dix huit vous
écriviez première tâche du gouvernement
et edf
célébrer le culte du président pas un
soupir pas une virgule pas à silence de
l'eau de l'elysée qui ne soit aussitôt
amplifié loup et commentés et présenté
par une presse quasi unanime comme le
plus étincelant joyaux de la couronne
très bien vous avez persiste et je signe
le rôle de l'opposition je fais ta liste
d'arguments
vous avez raison seulement l'hôte de
l'élysée change du coup change dans nos
temps il ya une grande là vous ne
persiste et pas par centaines
j'en reçois les doubles les témoignages
d'écrivains de cinéastes de pain de
compositeurs affluent vers le président
c'est vrai au pour lui dire en pratique
c'est vrai mais il ya une à l'heure jean
d'ormesson la re on est arrivé au bout
de ce qu'est ce que vous êtes ministre
de la culture
ou peut-être d'une diversion de masse
efficace mais surtout dans la jonglerie
ou pire un ministre de la propagande
culturelle
il y a une grande différence monsieur
d'ormesson entre l'ancien président et
le président actuel
jadis c'était le gouvernement de la
parole c'était le gouvernement de
l'apparence aujourd'hui c'est le
gouvernement de l'action
nous sommes des bâtisseurs nous sommes
des constructeurs voient la principale
des différences la culture est forcément
du côté par jean neveu som le temps à la
parole à isabelle je profite de ce que
vous êtes de ce que notre ami charles
trenet est là aujourd'hui pour vous
demander vous êtes favorable à sa
candidature à l'académie française
réputée
pour une fois je suis très tranquille
parce que je peux parler très librement
ce qui arrive très rarement aux
académiciens le figaro magazine vous
parler différemment vous avez librement
à toute la place et sur l'année le temps
que celle du nidcd exemple mais comme
exemple d'intolérance on ne fait pas
mieux
auj ensuite je crois que j'ai mes deux
blocs très bon jour et la nuit entre le
pouvoir et l'opposition jamais je ne
dirai jamais ça jamais j'adore jaune aux
mêmes ont aussi intolérant que le soir
alors pour l'académie alors je suis
absolument engager envers quelqu'un que
je considère comme un excellent tribun
et que je souhaite que voir entrer à
l'académie qui est michel bord donc pour
une fois voilà un cas rare un
académicien qui dit pour qui ils votent
et qui il souhaite voir entrer à
l'académie
merci alors svp philippe harrouard les
questions beaucoup de questions la
culture nous fait remarquer une
téléspectatrice de royan la culture
commence avec l'éducation des enfants et
ce soir on en parle absolument pas là
lors de la 10 le ministre le dit autre
question quelle mesure comprend le
ministre pour l'entrée de la culture
vraiment à l'école théâtre la musique la
danse de dessins les arts plastiques etc
oui je crois avoir déjà répondu à la
question posée avec monsieur savary et à
la demande du président de la république
nous préparons en ce moment un projet de
loi sur l'éducation artistique qui aura
pour objet précisément de généraliser
l'éducation artistique à l'école par
exemple pourriez y est une machine qui
vient de sortir machine à enseigner la
musique
bon on n'est pas très avancé dans ce
domaine là mais effectivement là il se
trouve qu'il a une création française
est ce qu'une machine comme ça vous la
préconiseriez dans les établissements
scolaires je veux dire c'est un micro
ordinateur
oui c'est monsieur bergé un français qui
a mis au point cette machine c'est pour
les enfants de 4 5 ans c'est leur permet
d'apprendre le solfège en s'amusant et
c'est une bonne petite méthode que le
jeu l'art directeur de la musique
nous avons intégré complètement dans
notre réflexion et recherche les moyens
modernes d'enseignement mais c'est un
instrument je crois très utile
une autre vidéo de svp totalement
différente pourquoi vous présentez vous
monsieur le ministre aux élections
municipales dans le 3e arrondissement de
paris ne vous sentez vous pas parachutée
votre travail ministériel n'est-il pas
suffisant je suis conseiller sortant
j'ai été élu en 1977 est normal que je
me représente
autre question si un ministre de giscard
avait fait la bise à un ministre
africain comme vous l'avez fait à fidel
castro lors de votre récent voyage à la
havane
qu'auriez vous dit
je répondrai puisque la question est
importante avec quelques précisions la
libération du poète cubain armando
valladares valait bien un déplacement à
laval et puisque l'interlocuteur évoque
monsieur giscard d'estaing je peux
affirmer que ni monsieur chirac ni
monsieur giscard d'estaing pour s'en
préoccuper avant notre arrivée de la
libération ce poète comme d'autres
poètes emprisonnés et si le président
françois mitterrand n'avait pas insisté
pour cette libération
ce pour elle serait toujours emprisonnés
et là comme ailleurs
notre gouvernement agit pour les droits
de l'homme
quels que soient les pays quelle que
soit l'attitude vous l'avez observé
encore avant-hier l'écrivain sud
africain brian bach qui a choisi la
france comme patrie provisoire
hanté par oui encore une question
concernant
disons le coût pour chaque français de
la culture le prix du cinéma nous dit on
a augmenté de 25% et plus depuis mai 81
les prix réduits du lundi ne profite pas
aux travailleurs mais aux professions
libérales les smicards sont oubliés oui
c'est une vraie question
monsieur d'ormesson qui souhaiteraient
qu'il n'y ait pas mystère la culture
vous dirais que le cinéma relève
principalement de l'initiative privée
des exploitants de salles c'est eux qui
fixent les tarifs des entrées dans les
salles de cinéma
naturellement en discutant avec
l'administration des finances
nous avons obtenu cependant des
exploitants qu'ils modèrent leurs prix
l'année prochaine les prix de places de
cinéma n'augmenteront que de 7%
par ailleurs je voudrais faire savoir à
l'ensemble des familles nombreuses que
nous avons obtenu des exploitants qu'à
l'avenir il y ait des réductions très
importantes pour les familles nombreuses
et je souhaite qu'elles puissent en
bénéficier au maximum
cependant il ya d'autres progrès à
accomplir
nous en discutons avec les exploitants
et nous espérons bien petit à petit
contribuer à la reconquête du public
populaire et c'est vrai que les prix de
places de cinéma sont parfois encore
trop élevé pour beaucoup de familles
nous serons attentifs et nous essaierons
d'obtenir des améliorations
alors une question monsieur le ministre
nous revient extrêmement souvent pensé
vous instituez un statut pour les
professeurs d'école municipale de
musique ou bien pensez-vous créer un
statut de professeur directeur de
conservatoires municipaux
en fait les téléspectateurs ont l'air de
dire bon d'accord la culture pour tous
et dans les plus petites villes
mais est-ce que ça suive pour les
professeurs d'école de musique par
exemple
mais je pense que la question posée
c'est concerne le point suivant
est ce que vous avez décidé de
d'élaborer un statut qui garantissent un
minimum de formation professionnelle
pour les éducateurs de musique et le
rôle de l'état encore un des rôles de
l'état tout à fait normal en france est
de protéger les familles
notre devoir est de vérifier si un
éducateur de musique rempile minimum de
conditions professionnelles
pour exercer un pari métier nous allons
d'ailleurs très bientôt pour la danse
faire adopter un texte qui préserve les
familles à l'égard de professeur de
danse qui n'auraient pas la
qualification
à propos de danse justement on nous dit
que le budget de la musique et de la
danse qui est un seul et même budget je
crois à une partie très faible pour la
danse 10% alors pouvez vous faire un
plus gros effort financier pour la danse
la danse a connu une augmentation très
importante au sein du budget de la
musique de près de 50% depuis un an et
demi je reconnais que ça a été longtemps
l'un des secteurs sacrifiés l'émission
la culture et une politique hardie est
en préparation en ce moment nous avons
ouvert un certain nombre de centres pour
la danse à travers différentes villes de
france et l'un des grands projets vous
le savez consiste à créer à marseille
sous l'impulsion de roland petit une
école nationale de la danse sud ministre
on nous fait remarquer vous n'avez pas
répondu tout à l'heure à la question sur
les 33 % de la tva sur les disques on ne
le fera remarquer très souvent alors je
vous pose la question
c'est vrai que la tva sur le disque est
une source d'alourdissement du prix du
disque
c'est vrai que nous souhaitons un jour
pouvoir diminuer ce taux ne pouvons pas
tout faire en même temps il faut en même
temps gérer avec soin et rigueur les
finances publiques
j'espère qu'un jour nous pourrons
diminuer cette tva à la condition
évidemment que cette diminution se
répercute sur le prix des disques et
puis on nous demande également si la
journée de la musique a coûté cher
et à quoi at elle servi au juste
si la plupart des initiatives prises par
le ministère coûter aussi peu cher
nous serions très riche je crois pouvoir
dire que pas plus de 30 300 mille francs
ont été dépensés dans cette action et
pour l'indiquer aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils ne seraient pas c'était le 21
juin dernier à notre appel
des dizaines de milliers de musiciens
amateurs et professionnels dans toutes
les communes de france sont sortis dans
la rue
fêtant la naissance de l'été et ont
ainsi témoigné de leur goût pour la
musique et j'espère que l'année
prochaine nous pourrons à nouveau
organiser cette grande fête de l'amitié
entre l'ensemble des musiciens français
n'étaient pas et ne seraient pas un
effet pervers cette politique parce que
plus on encourage la musique en france
et est plus finalement on favorise les
importations d'instruments étrangers
mais on n'est pas capable de fabriquer
nos instruments de musique dans vase est
une question incidence mais vous avez
entièrement raison
c'est une vraie question dans la mesure
où il y en ce moment en france un vrai
engouement pour la musique la mesure où
il ya une politique favorable à la
pratique de la musique comme les
instruments français sont très rares
cela conduit à une situation nous devons
importer 80% des instruments de musique
alors que notre pays était exportateur
après la guerre il est importateur
d'instruments de musique et cela
représente en effet une hémorragie
importante de devises
demain matin nous rendons public un plan
de relance pour les instruments de
musique qui associera l'ensemble des
professionnels instruments musique
traditionnelle le piano cordes mais
aussi instruments de musique plus
moderne et je pense notamment au
synthétiseur de son encore une question
qui s'adresse à monsieur jacques lang
homme de théâtre sans doute pensez vous
que le théâtre non professionnels un
rôle important à jouer dans le domaine
culturel si oui quelle mesure envisagez
vous de venir pour venir en aide à ces
nombreuses compagnies qui manque le plus
souvent de moyens
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec cet
interlocuteur le théâtre amateur comme
la musique amateur
c'est l'une des meilleures écoles de
préparation en tout cas c'est l'école
qui donne l'envié qui donne le désir qui
donne l'appétit et rien ne remplacera
jamais c'est ce désir et cet appétit
nous avons encouragé le théâtre amateur
en mettant à sa disposition un minimum
de moyens et je crois que le mouvement
amateurs théâtrale comme musicale se
développe beaucoup et la fête de la
musique a été l'un des moyens pour faire
connaître l'ensemble des groupes
amateurs de musique
svp oui oui alors une question
nous a souvent été posée que comptez
vous faire pour faciliter l'accès des
salles de spectacles donc de la culture
aux handicapés des mesures ont été déjà
été ont déjà été prises mais on ne peut
les prendre avec commodité que dans les
nouvelles salles voici un mois et demi
j'ai inauguré la maison de la culture du
havre et j'ai pu constater que les
constructeurs et en particules
architecte oscar niemeyer avait envisagé
et exécuter des améliorations pour les
handicapés et comme vous le savez les
améliorations pour les bâtiments anciens
sont difficiles à réaliser
néanmoins des directives sont donnés à
chacun pour au fur et à mesure
répondre aux besoins des handicapés et
des parois d'autres questions oui oui
j'ai beaucoup d'autres questions par
exemple on nous pose souvent cette
question pourquoi les places d'opéra
coûte elle aussi cher je suppose que
c'est à paris elles sont un coût
prohibitif nous dit à un téléspectateur
de nogent pour les gens non fortunés
oui en même temps en même temps on peut
on peut dire exactement l'inversé parce
que il y avait un papier très
intéressant dans le monde des deux jours
deux doigts de vos collaborateurs sur la
question qui montrait comment
finalement ce sont les gens vivent
l'opéra qui bénéficie le plus des
subventions culturelles de votre
ministère l'avait cité des chiffres
assez impressionnant c'est une question
difficile questions vraiment difficiles
les prix des places sont élevés oui mais
là encore il faut que quelqu'un paye ou
bien c'est le contribuable ou bien c'est
le spectateur
si nous faisions baisser brutalement les
prix des places à l'opéra ça voudrait
dire que le contribuable va apporter une
subvention plus importante et par
conséquent en effet assez injuste car
l'opéra ne bénéficie malheureusement pas
à l'ensemble des français à ce jour
alors une des solutions pour permettre
au prix de places de baisser et
précisément l'ouverture dans quelques
années place de la bastille de ce futur
opéra qui sera un opéra de 3000 places
nous assurons un grand nombre de
représentations et j'espère qu'à ce
moment-là nous réussirons à baisser
substantiellement le prix des places bon
monsieur ministre alors conformément à
la tradition des missions vous disposez
maintenant d'une minute pour conclure et
peut-être plus partie quand vous vous
adressez aux jeunes qui attendent leurs
deux des enfants du rock c'est vrai
d'ailleurs on n'a plus peur là peut
parler des jeunes ce soir c'est bien
regrettable
sans vouloir la récapituler tout ce qui
a été fait pour les jeunes depuis un an
et demi ils ont été pour beaucoup dans
nos préoccupations création de salle de
répétition pour les groupes de musique
ouverture de deux monuments historiques
aux enfants et aux jeunes chantier de
restauration etc
mais il faut conclure et malheureusement
je ne peux pas aborder ce sujet
simplement je voudrais dire puisque vous
parlez des jeunes que dans cette
révolution technologique en cours
la jeunesse aura un rôle déterminant à
jouer c'est elle qui est la force de
préparation de demain c'est pareil en
particulier que nous apprendrons nous
les adultes formés à une autre culture
les instruments de culture et demain
rien de tel pour vous enseigner le
maniement un ordinateur qu un enfant de
8 ans qui très vite manipule l'appareil
mais je voudrais surtout pour conclure
dire que malgré les polémiques les
procès d'intention et au delà ces
polémiques et des procès d'intention
ce gouvernement et ce ministère en
particulier est un ministère de
bâtisseur et de constructeurs et que
rien ne nous détournera de notre volonté
tranquille paisible calme de construire
pas à pas une société plus juste une
société plus fraternelle et en même
temps nous savons bien que ce n'est pas
l'état seul qui pourra le faire et que
chacun doit être l'artisan du changement
chacun doit apporter sa pierre à la
maison commune c'est un élan c'est un
enthousiasme et en partie de la jeunesse
qui permettra à notre pays de sortir de
la crise et de connaître la renaissance
économique et culturel
je n'ai pas de doute quand je vois
autour de moi des jeunes des moins
jeunes des industriels des créateurs que
beaucoup d'entre eux souhaitent que
notre pays s'en sortent beaucoup d'entre
eux sont comme dirait rené char habité
par l'état d'esprit du soleil levant
allons de l'avant sans se décourager ou
demeurant la vie ne plus jamais les
voiles et comme au premier jour
je propose qu ensemble avec tous ceux
qui veulent créer embellir la vie nous
ouvrions de nouvelles frontières et nous
nous lancions vers la préparation de
nouveaux horizons celui ce je vous
remercie
prochains invités raymond barre qui fera
sa rentrée télévisée dans l'heure de
vérité le jeudi 13 janvier devant soir
[Musique]